so this is very interesting um uh wha
i've been on fox news before and when i
was on fox news
i was interviewed by a guy named leland
vidert and um leland vitter
at least typically i don't know his
personal politics but he certainly
plays a right winger on fox news he's no
friend of the left when i was
interviewed on fox news
uh by leland vitter i was opposite some
right-wing radio host but it very
quickly became
the right-wing radio host and leland
vittert against me
no problem i expected it okay it's none
of that is notable but leland vitter is
not our friend
but over the weekend leland vitter kind
of flipped out
on a trump campaign flunky who refused
to explain
where would trump get the votes to flip
the multiple states he needs to flip to
win this election
and the first part of this video i'm
going to play for you
is where it starts to heat up because
leland
very astutely points out you know you
vaguely
talked about hundreds of thousands of
votes in pennsylvania you throw out
these numbers
but in terms of what you're actually
contesting what is donald trump's path
to victory
what happened with these votes and what
exactly could happen to give donald
trump a victory aaron perrini is a trump
campaign
staffer director of press communications
she can't answer the question or won't
answer the question
and it starts to heat up take a look
what do you want to have happen with
those 700 000 votes the ballots are
already mixed in
do you just want 700 000 votes deducted
from buying sure that conversation
happens
you're trying to say this is done and
over there i'm not i'm i'm not done
i've done it over i'm asking where
you're gonna find the votes
where are the votes to pull out forward
the
this is now my third time to try to get
this answer out the legal path ahead
exists here
because there are clear constitutional
violations that enhance
keep searching so you can repeat the
phrase constitutional violations all day
long
you still have to prove them but what is
the path for trump to win
is the question let's get back to it and
now cornered
by a fox news right winger never mind uh
you know mind you she switches to
attacking fox news
hypocrisy continues because you know
what how does the president don't
save the joe biden
so she again goes back to this idea that
the court has to decide
i i really want to again explain how
this is a red herring
the court only has to decide anything
if they have something to decide and
they would only have something to decide
if they find merit to the claims that
are being made before the court
courts have not found merit they meaning
the trump campaign wants you to think
until a court and by the way which court
until a court has weighed in they want
you to think it's not over
courts don't need to be involved in
elections unless there's a reason for
courts to be involved and so far courts
have found
that they don't need to be involved
multiple lawsuits have been either
thrown out
or even retracted so don't fall for that
let's continue with the interview
okay that is up for the court to decide
but we should be able to have the
conversation about those nobody when
you're trying to say this
no nobody's trying to say that i'm just
simply asking you you guys keep
how is that president-elect i don't know
who you are i don't know who you got i
don't know who you guys
are okay you and i are having crime i'm
trying to have a conversation with you
and i'm aaron perrini
i'm trying to work with the president of
the united states i'm trying to ask you
very simply where are you going to find
the votes you say we want to count every
vote
conceivably because you think that means
you're going to pull ahead
where are the votes in a path to 270
where we are taking every legal
avenue that exists in these states to
make sure
that legal votes are counted and illegal
votes are counted so there erin perrini
actually slips
up and says to make sure illegal votes
are
counted she's not even able to keep
track of her own arguments but this
really is the crux of it
in these states that they are contesting
claiming that they are contesting
even if donald trump got his way like
even if there was a recount
even if there's some batch of votes that
they are contesting
which was all for him instead of for joe
biden
none of it would even overturn the
election results and this is what she
continues to refuse to admit as it heats
up
even more here's a question for you
leland for every democrat and every
talking head on the news
how much fraud is okay how many dead
people can vote and you're okay with
that
how many ballots are run through all the
times and you're okay with that
no it's a serious question we want to
protect election integrity in the united
states
and we said for months that we wanted to
know when you start saying you died who
are you lumping everybody together with
you guys really the media the media and
the media in general so now it's just
you just attack everybody if they don't
agree with you okay
um no not much not much to say
aaron we understand where you want where
you want to go with this thank you we
appreciate your time
jillian always so that wraps up
the segment and there are there are kind
of a few different angles here
first is the continued hilarity of trump
is going after fox for acknowledging
reality trump's mad at fox
because fox acknowledges biden one but
at night the nighttime fox clowns are
still parroting these ideas that
the election was stolen by joe biden now
number two
how long can the trump campaign keep
doing this one pennsylvania lawsuit
was over 40 000 votes biden won by 72
000 in pennsylvania so again even if
all of the contested ballots were to go
for trump
it still wouldn't change the result and
understand
how radical things have gotten that a
fox news
anchor simply reporting election results
is considered an attack on donald trump
they claim
everybody else are triggered snowflakes
but if you tell them hey
these are the election results they
march on washington dc
chanting fox news sucks it's almost like
fox news has radicalized these people so
much
that they are now too radical even for
fox news acknowledging
hey we had an election and joe biden won
it's a horrifying reality that we live
in
and we'll talk more about fox's own role
in this radicalization a little bit
later
uh also make sure that you're following
us on instagram for more on this
at david pakman show i want to let you
know that our sponsor vincero watches
is having a massive holiday sale on all
of their products right now
and you can take advantage of it by
going to davidpakman.com
watch a brand new high quality
wristwatch
really is the perfect way to add
something
fresh to your style whether it's for you
or a gift for someone else
vincero is a brand that has a serious
dedication to the craft of watchmaking
which is really evident when you look
closely at their watches
i wear vincero watches myself lately
i've been wearing one from their icon
automatic collection it's the mesh matte
black
watch and i love the sleek minimalist
design
their watches are actually sold at a
fair price their mission has always been
to make a wrist watch
from high-end materials but one that
everyday people can afford
and that's why they have over twenty
five thousand
five star reviews because you won't find
a better made watch
for this great of a price anywhere else
you can get big holiday discounts on all
of their products right now
and free shipping when you go to
davidpakman.com
watch i've put the link right underneath
this video